dr. David Aronoff is the director of the
division of infectious diseases at
Vanderbilt University Medical Center in
Nashville good morning dr. Aaron off you
saw the pictures some quite large crowds
sometimes shoulder-to-shoulder without
masks what concerns you most when you
look at pictures like that well thanks
for having me on I think the major
concern here is that the virus
transmitted from person to person
through our breath and our breath in
these little respiratory droplets
travels a short distance and so the
shorter distance that there is between
people the more likely there is to be a
transmission event and that's really
what's concerning if we're concerned
about a spike in cases now how do we
prepare for that
how does States prepare for it well we
prepare a lot like we did when the kovat
19 pandemic was first coming to the
United States which is making sure that
we have the healthcare personnel ready
to go that we have personal protective
equipment the PPE that we need and that
we're doing all the testing that we can
to identify cases as they surge and if
they surge when when as we're looking at
slowly reopening and and most states of
all states actually have now begun that
process how do we assess the risk of
easing social distancing well that's
really the challenge right now that
we're all facing and I think again one
of the pathways forward here is having a
good ability to test people and identify
cases get people who are infected to be
able to self quarantine and then even be
able to trace their contacts to try and
track down people who may have been
infected
the Trump administration has has largely
left testing and the response to this
virus to the states do you think that's
the right approach or do we need some
kind of uniform national strategy and
recommendations at least
well we're learning a lot as this
pandemic has been unfolding about the
importance of coordinating state-level
efforts with federal efforts and I think
really we need good solid public health
infrastructure from top to bottom and
certainly State Department's of Public
Health are working overtime to make sure
that people within their state are safe
and I think it's still good to be
continuing to invest in State Public
Health is a lot of health comes experts
are concerned about a second wave as I
mentioned do you believe a second wave
is is inevitable and if so when is it
most likely to occur well I think we're
going to see second waves for sure the
question will be where we see those and
how extensive they are again we may be
more likely to see second waves in
larger more populated areas that open up
sooner than others and so it really may
be a bit of a patchwork quilt where we
see different cities that have waves of
activity even out of synchrony with
other cities and so the country is very
large and I think we can expect to see
waves coming and going as we open up and
that'll tell us how aggressively we
should be opening up or whether we
should be dialing back and adding more
restrictions in some sites all right dr.
David Aronoff at Vanderbilt University
thanks so much for being with us this
morning